you think about this right once you put
an expression this putz this pottery
it's an expression okay once you put it
together an equal sign and make an
equation things change things change
dramatically this is what I'm trying to
label a point on the fact that these
things are different to each other okay
what's different what do you remember
some of the questions that you did
yesterday okay
they would give you an expression okay
expression might be something like K
plus 3 okay and then they said remember
what we did was the I'm heading of
yesterday's lesson some decision exactly
right
we didn't do we served in all I can
paint right I can substitute different
values of K into here right so they said
you know when K equals and then they
asked you for a number like say when K
equals 1
okay what is this expression equal to
and the answer is four good but just as
equally I could make a something else if
I wanted I could say how about when K is
equal to 20 and you can still work it
out you'd go in substituted you get 20
plus 3 which is 23 okay and I can do
this for as many values as I like right
so in other words K here we used to
study that it's a pretty robust variable
right it can change and you can produce
but now have a look at what's happened
over here now that we put it in an
equation this expression in an equation
okay could just be anything we like
anymore Kenneth you can't just put in a
number and say I want that to be K
there's only one value of K
that actually makes sense right what's
the value of K that makes sense
Liam yeah - its - he's on the ball
straight back mother
of course it's to be close to +3 that's
equal to 5 and there's no other number
that you can put into K that'll make it
work does that make sense
I like if you put in if you put in one
or twenty or fifty five all those kinds
of things you won't get an equation
anymore because these things would be
equal okay so that number there in this
case can't equals two it's very very
important it's the one value that makes
it work I write that down the value of K
that makes
the equation work okay now that's very
very informal language let me try and
make it a little more formal and
detailed for you instead of saying the
value K that makes the equation work
that's that little bit there okay
another way that you'll hear this set is
it's the value K I'll just write the
whole thing the value okay now this is a
bit tricky but stay with it means
exactly the same thing that satisfies
the equation what does the word satisfy
me when do we tend to use it yeah yeah
it's like I'm satisfied this is good
this is uh this is nice I'm pleased did
this okay it works right I'm content
with it so this is a better way of
saying this is a more formal way K
equals two is value of K that satisfies
this equation that makes it but that's
still a bit of a mouthful isn't it it's
on the honkers it so instead boiling it
all down this we turn this into this and
even more succinct arms concise way of
saying it is I'm take us to recall that
the solution that's it it's a weird kind
of word right but it's kind of short for
all of this k goes to is the solution of
this equation okay so in other words you
know they're worth solution they are
better at a noun what's the verb it goes
it's a solution I think it's
so isn't it salt if you saw something
you get a solution so I could say I
could say Sol K plus three equals five
does that make sense I can't a solvent
which means find the value of K that
makes it work that satisfies it you
would say K equals two
that's the one that makes it look okay
please get across to you remember how I
said expressions and equations not the
same right I can't say I can't say so k
plus three because this is an expression
right it doesn't care what case okay
can't be anything right it's only when
you've got an equation and suddenly K is
limited it can only equal some things in
this case it can only think one thing
now let's come back excuse me
pause for a second I want you to I'm
gonna ask you a question and don't use
shadow I want you to form an answer in
your head in words before the question
how about to post it might seem simple
okay well I want you to see if you can
wear it for yourself I gave you this
equation right and then I asked all of
you yeah
what's the value came that actually make
it work what's that what's the solution
okay
and you all came up with this now here's
the question how did you come up with
that number I should think about in you
here you put into a sentence I came up
with two because
okay now wonder if we can get a couple
of different answers what your echo is
here okay sir so you took away 3 from
this number and that gave you two cool
that works all right
did someone have something different a
different way of doing it
yeah today yes and yeah okay yep good so
the difference between 5 & 3 is 2 and
that makes it work okay good
all of these I'll fight we arrived at
the right answer didn't we so what else
might say well I just I just thought
about different numbers like I tried one
but one doesn't what is it you're gonna
one in you're like oh I'm for it sorry
try again right so you try another table
up so guess and check okay you can
arrive at the answer very very quickly
because it's an easy equation it's
pretty simple isn't it
but if I give you a harder one guess and
check all these methods we looked at
they're not gonna be as good so I need
to illustrate this for you